book state of war the secret history of
the CIA and the Bush administration Jim
on behalf of the students at the
University of Denver and George Mason
University and Pace University welcome
glad to have you thanks for having me
let me begin where you begin in the book
George Tenet CIA director you describe
him this way in public George Tenet
struck a pose as an honest broker of
intelligence in private he was sometimes
seen as someone who would tell people
what they wanted to hear but later say
the opposite to others was that
emblematic of some of the problems that
led to the build-up of the war and his
own stewardship at the CIA yeah I think
it was one of the problems you had I
think prior to the war was that what you
might describe as a perfect storm people
in positions at the State Department or
at the CIA who could have stood up and
said something or done something did not
do it and I think one of those key
people was George Tenet
tenet as CIA director was the custodian
of classified intelligence at a time
when the United States was for the first
time in its history going to war based
almost exclusively on classified
intelligence and rather than speak up at
a point when he could have said there
have been some misleading statements
made or the debate right now is
oversimplified he did not and yet a
couple of the ironies first of all you
point out that George Herbert Walker
Bush saved George Tennant's job as his
son was elected president why there was
a tenant as you know was a Clinton
appointee to begin with he was appointed
CI director in 1997 after a series of
miscues
at the CIA john deutsch was the CI
director who was appointed in 1995 by
Bill Clinton and tenet was appointed as
his deputy tenet had prior to that being
a White House staffer dealing with
intelligence programs
and then earlier in his career had been
staff director of the Senate
Intelligence Committee he came in as
deputy director of the CIA under
Deutsche enjoyed to be extremely
unpopular at the CIA and also made it
clear he did not want the job and he was
hoping to become defense secretary in
the second Clinton administration the
second Clinton term and when he did not
get that job after the 96 election he
quit Anthony Lake who was the national
security adviser at that time for Bill
Clinton was nominated to be CI director
Republicans in Congress decided made it
clear they did not want Lake
they fought his nomination and his
nomination imploded and so after Lake
withdrew tenet that became C who was
nominated by Clinton almost by default
because they were running out of people
in 2001 he he was still he was one of
the only Clinton people still in the
government during the transition and
leading up to the to the new Bush
administration in not in Wow President
Clinton was still president though he
had made it clear that he was willing to
kind of work both sides of the fence as
it were a he you know the Congress
decided to name the CIA headquarters
after President Bush the first president
Bush mister tenet arranged for
conferences by the CI to be held at the
Bush Presidential Library during the
Clinton years and a mr. tenet arranged
for a number of brief intelligence
briefings for former President Bush
while he was but president clinton was
still in office and so there was an
impression left that he was making an
effort to ingratiate himself with the
Bush family let me take you all back to
the evening of September 11th 2001
remember President Bush was in Florida
he then traveled to a couple of
different locations including Louisiana
before ending up back in Washington late
in the afternoon
early evening delivered a speech to the
nation and this is part of what he had
to say about what happened in New York
in Shanksville Pennsylvania and here in
Washington at the Pentagon terrorist
attacks can shake the foundations of our
biggest buildings but they cannot touch
the foundation of America these acts
shatter steel but they cannot dent the
steel of American resolve the search is
underway for those who are behind these
evil acts I've directed the full
resources of our intelligence and law
enforcement communities to find those
responsible and to bring them to justice
we will make no distinction between the
terrorists who committed these acts and
those who harbor them so that pretty
much laid the groundwork for Iraq by
that that one sentence correct well I
think there was that was one of the
arguments certainly that the Bush
administration made there was after 9/11
in the 18 months between 9/11 and the
invasion of Iraq there was a very
vigorous debate within the government a
fight actually between the CIA and the
Pentagon over any effort to connect Iraq
to 9/11 and to al-qaeda and that was
really kind of the backstory to what was
happening to the the poisonous debate
poisonous relationship that developed
between the neoconservatives at the
Pentagon who were arguing that Iraq was
part of the war on terror and that Iraq
had something to do with al-qaeda and
the CIA which was saying Iraq had
nothing to do with 9/11 and Iraq has
nothing to do with al-qaeda and that led
to a whole series of arguments and
fights between the intelligence
community and between the office of
Secretary of Defense Rumsfeld and the
office of the Vice President Dick Cheney
so you have a CIA director who President
Bush basically inherits from the Clinton
administration and then you say in your
book that after 9/11 you describe this
as a relationship forged by fire the
President Bush had to rely on George
Tennant because he was the only person
in the inner circle who knew anything
about bin Laden
al Qaeda but there was Richard Clark who
was he
Clark was the counterterrorism czar at
the White House who was a career
official a career official he was also
the only was one of the only other
Clinton holdovers but he got pushed
aside very quickly after 9/11 why well
there was a sense in the Bush
administration the early days that Clark
had usurped power in the end of the
Clinton period and that he was had been
too much power had been concentrated in
his office at too low a level within the
White House there was a sense that they
wanted to restructure counterterrorism
very quickly I think it also became
clear that the Pentagon under Rumsfeld
wanted to assert its power over the
counterterrorism fight and take a lot of
power away from the National Security
Council at the White House I'm gonna
bring one other point to the table and
then we're gonna go to Chris Malone in
New York at Pace University and then to
Steve Klein at George Mason University
but you later in the book went with
regard to weapons of mass destruction
first of all you say that only one CIA
officer undercover working in Baghdad
prior to the war and you also talked
about how agency officials working in
that part of the world would get a lot
of misinformation because Saddam Hussein
had so many enemies so the question is
was there any way to verify what the
with these enemies of Saddam Hussein
were saying about weapons of mass
destruction about Saddam Hussein and
about where all these materials were
located I think the problem was you had
a lot of skepticism within the CIA over
the sources of information that was what
was coming in but within the Bush
administration that atmosphere has been
created I think that said we that made
it clear to the CIA what what answers
they wanted to hear and so there was a
predilection that developed over time
that people and sources that said there
would that confirmed the existence of
WMD we're listened to and their reports
from those people shot to the top
anybody who raised questions about the
existence of WMD
or question the quality of the
intelligence it was all seen as part of
Saddam's denial and deception program so
in other words anybody who came to the
CIA and said there are no there is no
WMD they were looked at as fabricators
because that's what they thought
Saddam was trying to tell us and so it
became this vicious circle that anybody
who said there isn't any WMD is
obviously a liar and anybody who tells
us there is WMD is obviously telling us
the truth so we're gonna listen to that
and so there was this mindset that was
created where you always got the answer
you wanted many of these students in
this class may think that if you work in
an administration you have the defense
secretary you have the vice president
you have the Secretary of State they're
all on the same team they're all working
toward the same goal is that the case no
certainly not in the Bush administration
the the the breakdown in the interagency
process made I think a lot of and a lot
of people with it who have served in
this administration believed that it
became dysfunctional that the Pentagon
and the vice president's office really
created a back-channel to dominate
foreign policy and national security
policy at the while the Secretary of
State Colin Powell was kind of cut out
of the loop and the White House staff
was under Condoleezza Rice who was
national security adviser then was
largely very weak and was unable to
stand up to Rumsfeld and Cheney a
defining moment came two years and two
months ago February 2003 set the stage :
Powell is asked to go to the UN to do
what in order to get the information
that allowed him to say what we're going
to hear him say the Powell was asked to
make the presentation for the Bush
administration at the United Nations
making the case that there that Saddam
did have weapons of mass destruction
that he was an imminent threat to the
United States and he was used he went
out to the CIA for several days for
briefings and to develop a presentation
that was based on the classified
intelligence that the CIA
everything's led by George ten yes and
he asked George Tenet to come to the UN
and stand with him and so throughout the
presentation Tennant was sitting right
behind Powell so let's show you again
this exchange these remarks by Secretary
of State Colin Powell from 2003 and then
we'll come back to Chris Malone in New
York for more than 20 years my word and
by deed Sodom Hussein has pursued his
ambition to dominate Iraq and the
broader Middle East using the only means
he knows intimidation coercion and
annihilation of all those who might
stand in his way
for Sodom Hussein possession of the
world's most deadly weapons is the
ultimate trump card the one he must hold
to fulfil his ambition we know that
Saddam Hussein is determined to keep his
weapons of mass destruction he
determined to make more given sodom
Hussein's history of aggression given
what we know of his grandiose plans
given what we know of his terrorist
associations and given his determination
to his that exact revenge and those who
opposed him should we take the risk that
he will not someday use these weapons at
a time the place and in a manner of his
choosing at a time when the world is in
a much weaker position to respond the
United States will not and cannot run
that risk through the American people
leaving Saddam Hussein in possession of
weapons of mass destruction for a few
more months or years is not an option
not in a post September 11th world well
that is the words I think that today
Colin Powell regrets more than anything
he's ever said in his public life I know
that he and the people around him today
feel betrayed by the CIA they feel that
they were misled and Powell has made it
clear that he doesn't hold George Tenet
personally responsible but he and the
people around him are have been very
defensive about the role that mister
was kind of pushed into playing and the
way in which the intelligence was
misused let's get to questions and
comments
we'll begin with Pace University thank
you Steve
mr. Rison thanks for being with us my
class here in New York has been reading
your book all semester with interests
and they have a ton of questions so I'm
gonna go right to my students because I
know that they want to engage in
conversation so Omar ESA's first and he
has your book right in front of him
great
there you go that's just which topics
for a moment I hope that's not I think I
wanted to play devil's advocate for a
second you know on sources the
importance of anonymous anonymous
sources I just want to say what's your
perception or what you think of how this
affects people's viewpoint on an
integrity of a journalist that's a good
question I mean it's it's difficult in
what I do I cover national security
issues foreign policy and I do trying to
do investigative reporting and frankly
today it's impossible to do that without
it using anonymous sources you can see
that the Bush administration is anxious
to conduct leak leak investigations of
people who talk to the press and there
is simply no way to get around providing
and the granting anonymity in order to
get people to talk about things that are
highly classified and secret about which
the American people should know about
and so I think the only answer is to in
the end trust you you have to build up
trust and credibility as a journalist
and that you have to kind of as a reader
have to rely on the source of the
information you're getting now when Dana
priest at the Washington Post writes a
story about secret CI prisons you know
that Dana priest is a fantastic reporter
The Washington Post is a great newspaper
and so you're trusting the fact that
you're getting this from a very credible
source even though it's all anonymously
sourced and so I think that's what you
have to do if that she is a much more
credible respected source than some
anonymous blogger on the internet that
you happen to find through Google and so
I think that's what you have to keep in
mind in this kind of debate I know it's
an unsatisfactory answer in a lot of
ways but I don't think there's any way
around the use of anonymous sources and
I think as a result you have to
recognize the quality of of the four of
the reporter and of the institution that
they work for as kind of a way to judge
whether or not it's believable and also
you look at the track record of the
reporter Omar it's a good question and
there's some electronic journalism
students at George Mason University we
also have some comm students at the
University of Denver we'll go to Steve
Kline next from George Mason thank you
Steve we have a couple questions but I
have to follow up what what mr. Eisen
just said by asking if Dana priest then
what about Judith Miller
you know that's the that's the obvious
the downside to it is that sometimes we
in the press get used by particularly by
senior government officials who want to
get out you know their version of events
and so it's it's it's a very tricky
business and there's no easy way around
it I mean even with the problems that
we've had on the weapons of mass
destruction coverage its I don't see I
think even the the stories that that
that later ray skepticism about WMD and
said that they're the administration
policies or the administration had
distorted the intelligence those were
also based on anonymous sources to a
large degree and so I think it's you
can't you know kind of sort of throw the
baby out with the bathwater you can't
you just can't do reporting in this area
under the kind of in the kind of
atmosphere we have today in Washington
without anonymous sources and as I said
it's it's that old thing if you know
you've got to look at the track record
of the reporter and and if and try and
judge it from that Steve Kline will go
to the student next to George Mason
thank you Steve Kristina mr. Eisen I was
wondering why the times waited to
publish your wiretapping story until
after Bush was reelected well you know
it's the I think what The Times has said
publicly is that we held the story for
about a year Wow the we know we did
further reporting and while the you know
we did we had meetings with the Bush
administration they were very intent on
making sure that we did not run the
story and so I agreed with paper not to
get into all the details of what
happened but I can just say that in the
end I think what the paper did was a
great public service and it was a very
difficult decision in process made
difficult by the fact that the the White
House was eager for us not to publish
the story how did you find out about it
how did I find out about what the NSA oh
well
that goes back to the issue of anonymous
sources and what I can say is that there
were people in the government a number
of people in the government who believed
that this NSA program was illegal or
unconstitutional because they were
avoiding the courts and they were not
adhering to the law and so there were a
number of people who who came forward
and believed that this was kind of a
classic whistleblower issue where they
should come forward and tell the truth
to the and make sure the American people
knew about it
let's go to Denver I don't see a hand
yet
let's see dad three or four others okay
dad we'll start with you first thank you
good afternoon mr. Rosen I'm so glad you
could join us I do want to kind of tie
this together though I'm not impugning
your integrity or your honor but you are
affiliated to some extent with the New
York Times there they have had more
problems with credibility
I work there yeah okay but they have had
some definite problems with credibility
in the recent past and along with so in
addition to the unnamed sources I'm sure
you can see how the public might have a
problem yeah with with buying into all
of this oh no I understand that I
understand that it's it's difficult I
just I'm just saying that I don't see a
way around it because if you want if the
public wants to get information about
what's going on today what the bush
administration is doing apart from just
the official pronouncements of what the
administration is doing the only way you
can do it is with anonymous sources and
sometimes we get things wrong and
sometimes we get it right and so I think
as a reader you have to accept you have
to kind of verify your sources vet your
sources of information the same way a
reporter does you have to decide who you
believe and which reporters or which
media outlets you think you can trust
and I wish that it you know that it was
not so so difficult because I wish
everybody could talk publicly about
everything but that's just not the real
world well stay in Denver I see Mary
Jane's hand up we'll go to you next
Thanks and thank you mr. Eisen for
coming to speak with us today I want to
touch on what you just said about
anonymous sources and the fact that in
the public today and in reality some of
these things just can't be talked about
why do you think that that's the case
and specifically in your opinion why do
you think that say the NSA story was
more prominent than something that you
talked about in your book regarding
Saudi Arabia or weapons of mass
destruction or any other
books that you seem to cover quite
diligently why was this so repressed in
the mainstream media
well the Bush administration did a very
good job of keeping it secret they were
it was highly compartmented within the
government which means that only a very
few people within the government knew
about it and they made they went they
took great lengths to hide any knowledge
of this from anybody and so I think that
was why the fact that we you know
revealed the existence of that was news
and that I think was a had a big was a
big reason why that was the part of the
book that was more prominent we'll go to
Pace University next question next
question is from Keisha lar
I was actually I'm really interested in
the chapter of who authorized putting
him on pain medication that's one of my
favorite chapters but I was interested
in it and was the abundance of prisons
around the world that the administration
were building just to directly or
intense interrogation of these prisoners
and I was wondering that you mentioned
in the Geneva Convention that they were
in direct violation of it and why was it
that international officials haven't
really brought it to the attention I
haven't even done anything regarding
these can't on these prisons and I know
it's more than one you mentioned at
least I believe four or five when in
Egypt when in Cuba and I believe one in
the Middle East so I was wondering why
do you feel that international officials
are not really doing anything about this
well the Bush administration has worked
closely with the governments of the
countries where these prisons have been
based and they've gotten approvals from
these countries to allow them to do it
in return they've kept the location
secret and one main reason they want to
have these prisons overseas is to keep
these people out of the US legal process
they don't want to have any of these
people go to try
or ever be seen in public and they want
to be able to use interrogation
techniques against them that you could
not use in the United States and so
they're there they've gone to countries
where that kind of activity is accepted
in the third world Eastern Europe and so
it it raises a lot of moral and ethical
issues and legal issues in the United
States but in those countries the
government's have generally agreed to
allow it to happen as long as the
Americans keep secret about which
exactly which countries they're doing it
in Casey did you want to follow up on
that point yeah I actually read another
part I think it was within the same
chapter of the following one that you
mentioned that they kept the FBI
purposely out of the international
prisoners because they were definitely
made sorry make sure that these
international prisoners were given
justice he goes like push the clip we
just saw said bring them suggestion for
justice when in fact he's keeping them
from it yeah yes good point thank you
yeah there was a there was a I think one
of the most crucial decisions that
President Bush made after 9/11 was to
treat terrorism as a national security
rather than a law enforcement issue
prior to 9/11 terrorism cases had been
handled primarily by the FBI in the jet
and the Justice Department and the
efforts had focused on bringing
terrorists to justice in the United
States after 9/11 Bush decided that this
was a military national security and an
intelligence issue and he turned the he
made the CIA and them and the Pentagon
the lead agencies in the war on
terrorism the FBI and the Department of
Justice took back seats and that was I
think out of that decision float
everything else that's happened where
you no longer have and accepted under a
widely understood legal framework in
which to deal with prisoners that you
would have had if
were all brought to the United States
and I think all of the problems with
that we've seen in terms of detainee
abuse has flowed I think from that
decision not to use law enforcement
methods with this in this case before we
go back to George Mason a little bit
about yourself
why are you a journalist where'd you go
to school and where are you from well I
grew up in Bethesda Maryland and I went
to public schools in Maryland and then
went to Brown University and
northwestern for masters in journalism
and then I worked at a lot of small to
medium size newspapers I worked started
in Fort Wayne Indiana and worked my way
up and I covered Business and Economics
for a number of years and then I got
into covering intelligence about ten
years ago Steve Kline will get a couple
of questions from George Mason the final
four
thank you Steve do you feel that the
Bush administration contributed to
turning Afghanistan to a narco-state yes
I think they're more than whether what I
think I think there's a lot easier
question it's a good question it's not
so much important what I think it's what
people in the government think are the
people I talked to they are a number of
people who are deeply disturbed at the
failure of the administration to follow
up on Afghanistan after the initial
success there and I think a lot of
people in the government would argue
that that was one of the unintended
costs of the war in Iraq was that in
2002 within six months of succeeding and
overthrowing the Taliban and denying
al-qaeda its Afghan haven that we began
to pull resources out of Afghanistan and
lose focus on Afghanistan and focus much
more on Iraq and that one of the
corollary problems there was that
Afghanistan has always been a major
opium producer under the Taliban
last few years of the Taliban they had
cut back on opium production and in
order to avoid problems with warlords
out in the countryside who we were
trying to win over to fight the
remaining Taliban we the Bush
administration essentially looked the
other way at the the resurgence of opium
production and because the same people
we are trying to work with on counter
and terrorism programs are this are also
many of the drug lords and so today
Afghanistan I think 60% of the GDP of
Afghanistan is opium production and it
now accounts for almost 90 percent of
heroin in the world
Mindy Smith in Denver I see your hand
will get you in a moment but let's stay
with George Mason and another question
from Steve Klein's group thanks Steve
Steve let me ask them a two part two
part question and I'll pose both parts
of the question both parts together
given the cross-platform nature of media
today what does a company like the New
York Times see as its primary outlet or
vehicle and corollary to that did the
breaking news portions of the reporting
in your book best serve that primary
outlet well I think they would say that
the newspaper is still the primary
outlet although I guess the website is
becoming bigger and bigger all the time
the and I think that you know my the NSA
story appeared in the newspaper and so I
think that that is the primary platform
they still have they've they've not
really ever made a a big had a big
presence in other media in terms of
television or anything that compared to
other chains Steve did you want to
follow up on that point I'm sure that
mr. Eisen's aware of the new what post
radio station here in Washington DC
and the primary programming for that for
that station is reporters from the new
reporters from the Washington Post
perhaps I don't know if you've had any
contact with any of your colleagues from
the post but how does something like
that impact on a reporter such as
yourself as the platform's diversify and
if I could let me just sort of students
in Denver and New York are aware an all
news radio station is now moved on the
dial and so now we're WTOP used to be
it's now W WPT which is Steve Kline
pointed out is a Washington Post radio
station so reporters from the Washington
Post who have stories in the paper are
then interviewed during the course of
the day and it's a way for them as they
say there's always more to the story and
this is a way for the Washington Post to
brand itself on radio I hope I explained
that well sounds about right
anyhow your response to Steve Lyons
question well I think you know you know
I don't have it we don't have anything
like that at the New York Times they do
have other you know they have access to
getting on TV like this or radio
interviews and so we just I I don't
think that's highly organized at the New
York Times we don't have that kind of
outlet where it's everything is funneled
through that and so you know when you
write a book or you write a big story at
the Times you know you get asked to go
on TV by other media not by the New York
Times and you know you can kind of pick
and choose which ones you want to do
it's not mandatory and you don't get
paid anything for it and so you know
some people do it other people don't but
it's not as organized as what the post
is doing we're glad you picked this
class to come and join us let's go back
to Denver
Mindy Smith I think your ad your hand up
thanks for being patient go ahead the
book was written on the history of the
CIA and Bush administration what I was
wondering about what information you
obtain about the direction that these
institutions are going in the future
what's changing and what new
to change well that's the $64,000 a year
to find any WMD or the or the or the
mistakes they made in in saying there
was WMD when there wasn't that their
failure to prevent 9/11 which was before
the WMD issue was the other big
intelligence failure they had have led
to a reassessment of the organization of
the structure of the whole intelligence
community that is still ongoing and the
initial efforts to add a new structure
what they call the Director of National
Intelligence and a new umbrella
organization over the CIA I think is has
not done the job I think all it's done
is add a new layer of bureaucracy and I
think that at at heart what the u.s.
intelligence needs to get back to is the
basics of just recruiting more spies on
the ground who can tell them the truth
and no matter how many bureaucratic
organization charts you develop in
Washington that bottom line that it
doesn't change if if all if you don't
have some people who are going to tell
you the truth about what's going on in
the world it's just going to be garbage
in and garbage out eric Spengler I think
I had saw your hand up in Denver do you
have a question or comment yeah thank
you for joining us mr. Rison I thought
your book was incredible it was one of
the best investigative journalism pieces
I've ever read well thanks and Eric let
me I said what what what do you take
away from the book what did you learn
the most after having read it I guess
the biggest thing I took away was that
the Bush administration this entire time
has basically said you know we we we
just followed the intelligence community
and I think the book really lays out how
the intelligence was distorted and not
really listened to the way it could have
been especially with the instance of the
doctor from Cleve
went to Iraq and investigated the the
nuclear program and that type of stuff
but it just seemed really clear that
there wasn't good intelligence my
question basically is it seems to me
that Donald Rumsfeld shares a lion's
share of the blame for getting us into
the mess that we're in now as a
journalist I don't expect you to really
reveal your personal views about what
you think should happen with Rumsfeld
but what is your sense about people in
the defense department of the CIA on
Rumsfeld
especially taking into consideration the
fact that people like Richard Lugar have
basically hinted that they would support
his resignation in just an interesting
trivia he is the youngest and oldest
serving defense secretary is he not
yeah he was in Gerald Ford's
administration right he served as
Secretary of Defense in the Ford
administration thirty years ago more and
now he's back and it's a great question
it's something that I struggled with
because I think it's easy I think it's
not much of a stretch to say that within
the Bush administration among the people
who have served in the Bush
administration Rumsfeld is the most
widely hated person who is still there
and he has many people there can't
understand the real origins of his power
and why he's been able to get away with
what he's gotten away with and not so
much in terms of ideological beliefs but
just in terms of his bureaucratic sheer
bureaucratic power the interesting thing
is that if you look back at the first
Bush administration you had this group
of what a lot of critics would call
conservative ideologue the
neoconservatives led by Paul Wolfowitz
who was Rumsfeld's deputy who really
passionately believed in the need to
invade Iraq Rumsfeld was never
identified with that ideological group
of neoconservatives and yet he had the
bureaucratic power that really enabled
them to do what they wanted to do in the
Bush administration and I think to me
one of the things that I heard
Bewdley from people who had worked at
the White House was that what angered
the most was that Rumsfeld would ignore
things that the president asked him to
do or that the president policies that
the president had had made it clear he
approved Rumsfeld would ignore what the
president had said and keep going with
his own policy and I think the the
greatest disaster or the biggest mistake
was the decision to disband the Iraqi
army and to conduct a an intensive
de-baathification of Iraq which forced
hundreds of thousands of Iraqis to
oppose us and to really fly inflame the
insurgency and there were people at the
White House who simply couldn't
understand how Rumsfeld and Paul Bremer
and the people at the Pentagon would
allow that to happen
Chris Malone let's get a couple of
questions from pace let's take two or
three back-to-back so it's all yours
great okay William Travis you're up next
thank you for joining us mr. baizen
first off expanding on Rumsfeld why
hasn't President Bush overruled him
especially with Afghanistan after the
briefing by Colin Powell agreeing that
the opium fields in Afghanistan should
be exterminated but that was never
followed up on right and secondly why
was Bobby Charles ignored in his in his
push to exterminate the fields when by
the time he was let go by new Secretary
of State rice the revelations about the
Richard Clarke and the CIA warnings had
already become public that's this is
just another one of those that's a great
that's a great question because the
people who told me about the the fact
that Rumsfeld was often disobeying what
the president wanted were the same
people who couldn't understand how he
was getting away with it and I think it
gets back to the way in which President
Bush manages and that is he sees his job
as just lay out a broad vision and that
the people around him will then
implement it but I think the mistake
he's made and that is that often in
lumen tation is the strategy that if you
just say I've got a broad vision for
instance I want to Democratic Middle
East and then you say my subordinates
will pursue how to do that at some point
the actual implementation and how they
go about doing that becomes the strategy
and I think the mistake that the
president has made in many instances is
not getting down another level of detail
to say yes I've set forth a broad vision
for democracy in the Middle East now how
are we going to do it and instead he is
allowed enormous freedom of movement for
a few key aides like Rumsfeld and the
vice president will stay with Pace
University next question Rekha swanny
go ahead reg do mr. Eisen for joining us
I have two questions I guess I'll give
you one and then I'll get the second one
I I guess the main theme of your book is
that how foreign policy was shaping
intelligence and not the other way
around in which we would expect it to be
right and we pretty much were all pretty
much fooled in 2003 I mean I remember
back when I was a junior in high school
in 2003 and we were discussing in
classrooms whether we should go into
Iraq whether we shouldn't and these
stuff and I find myself now as a junior
in college discussing whether we should
go into Iran whether we should go into
Syria that we should do this and that
and I was just wondering because a lot
of these books like your book and the
9/11 Commission all these come de facto
after everything goes wrong so what do
we do in these instances well you know
I'm that's a good question I'm I'm just
a reporter I'm here to try and lay out
what I know and I'm not a politician
trying to decide what we should do I
mean other so what I've tried to do is
just lay out what people have told me
and then you guys the American people
get to decide what's the right policy
you know Iran now is obviously the next
issue frankly I think there are a lot of
people in the government who say you
know we are so tied down in Iraq I don't
see how we can do we don't have a lot of
freedom of movement with Iran and so I
think one I think Iraq will
really determine what we do with Iran to
a large extent ray did you want to
follow up yeah I had a different kind of
a question um within your book like you
know I don't know if there was maybe
perhaps God like because a lot of your
sources were from the CIA or whatnot but
it seems that you didn't mention a lot
of things within the CIA from the past
like when you were talking about Saddam
Hussein you didn't really um focus in
terms of how those chemical weapons got
to Saddam Hussein and how Rumsfeld was
very affiliated with in that also with
the Saudi Arabia arm chapter that it was
a CIA initiative to do that and also
Afghanistan became a narco-state in
terms because of the CIA support for
that a right all right or I can order to
fund on Osama bin Laden and the Taliban
kind of before September 11th than
before that right so I don't know was
that because like you used a lot of CIA
sources or all right well I think what I
was trying to do was focus on new
information and to kind of break news
about current events rather than go back
over a lot of other issues that we're
already pretty well known and pretty
well-documented in the past but that's a
good critic that's a valid criticism
that I guess if I had had more time to
do the book if I was going to do it
again I'd probably include more
historical context than I did well go to
Regan bird let next back in Denver and
then on to George Mason
hello mr. Eisen thanks for joining us um
my question has um I guess you could
call it like about the issue about the
lack of utilization and then transfer or
the lack of transfers between
information in the Bush administration
and I um like one thing that comes to
mind is like a report that I just heard
on like NPR I think they're doing like
an ongoing report about Guantanamo Bay
and they were talking about how the
officials there thought they were
receiving more serious prisoners and
they actually were and you kind of
mentioned that by saying like the really
serious prisoners are being sent to
those
secret CIA sites rather than being sent
to Guantanamo Bay where they had been in
the pasture or now
and so but an interesting thing is that
you know there's one prisoner that they
did a report on that said the only
evidence against him was that he was in
Afghanistan at some point in time the
CIA won't release when he was what he
was supposed to be doing then where he
was in Afghanistan they won't release
any of that information because it's
classified and so on
you know there's information that you
know that his family MERS was saying you
know he wasn't even there and he's never
been to Afghanistan but that's not being
allowed in this case so this needs to be
just relates to me a lot about how the
Bush administration it seems to be that
they don't want new information and then
when they get new information they hide
it as you were talking about that CIA
officer who was trying to send someone
to a site even though he had suspicions
that he was innocent you know so there's
either they don't want information and
and in a morning create a sort of
plausible deniability or when they get
information they're not going to use it
to change any decisions so I was gonna
my my question is basically that why is
this such a prominent problem in the
Bush administration specifically and
then you know how detrimental has this
treatment of information been to the
Bush administration good point thanks
Reagan yeah well I mean I think it's
many people have said that they think
this is the most secretive
administration in many years and I as a
reporter I would agree it's the most
difficult administration to cover in
terms of secrecy I think there there's
been some interesting stories that have
come out lately about the history that
related to this about the history of
Dick Cheney and and Don Rumsfeld and how
in the Ford administration when they
were serving in the White House they
were really upset at the reforms that
were put in place political reforms that
were put in place to limit the
intelligence community to limit secrecy
and to impose new openness requirements
on the government and there's a sense I
think in some of the stories that have
come out about that that they are now
kind of taking a some kind of a backlash
in their own minds against what happened
and that the reforms in the 70s Steve
Kline I promise I'm gonna pack to you
but I just I wanted to follow up on one
point have you ever given any thought as
to why George Bush selected Dick Cheney
as his running mate because it proved to
be an important policy decision yes I
think I cannot believe that he
understood what Cheney was going to
become in terms of the power that Cheney
has amassed I I would love to know this
but I think that Cheney and to a larger
extent Rumsfeld's appointment I think
Rumsfeld was really almost an accident
because they were very close to putting
dan coates in as Secretary of Defense a
former senator from Indiana and it was
only when Bush has interviewed coats
personally and they decided he didn't
like him that change that they went to
Rumsfeld now at that point I think
Cheney's role as Rumsfeld's old Protege
played a role but someone some prominent
people in the administration told me
that they think that Cheney saw that :
Powell
Cheney was worried about the power that
: Powell was going to have that you know
they while they had worked together in
the first Bush administration they
really weren't all that close and that
when at during the transition that he
that Cheney was worried that Powell and
the center of gravity and foreign policy
was going to be with Powell and that he
saw bringing in Rumsfeld as a way to
counterbalance Powell and you know I
guess then it became clear that pal
really wasn't the threat to Cheney that
he thought and and POW and Cheney and
Rumsfeld became very powerful is the
book that I can't wait to read is the
relationship between George Bush and
Dick Cheney now that's evolved over the
years let's go back to George Mason and
we'll take a couple of questions from
your folks Steve Kline thanks again
Steve
Portia Dawkins place
hello mr. Eisen is is there a real
relationship if the Blissett is the Bush
administration and the US intelligence
taking any action to investigate what
the relationship is between Saudi Arabia
and al-qaeda well they have not done
very much about it and that was one of
the points I tried to make in my book
which was that you know Saudi Arabia is
really the home of of al-qaeda and while
the administration was was going all out
to prove the links between Iraq and al
Qaeda they were very hesitant to raise
the issues of Saudi complicity or Saudi
involvement in funding or promoting
al-qaeda and Sunni fundamentalism and I
think that that's something that if if
this war on terrorism continues for much
longer
somebody is going to have to deal with
that issue because you know we have
avoided it because Saudi Arabia is you
know also the home of so much oil but
you know I'm not sure how long we can
continue to ignore that problem well
stay with George Mason next question
thank you
mad at first place what sort of
implications do you think the situation
in Iraq and the way in which it has been
handled will have on broader American
policy particularly in the Middle East
and Iran I think that the the most
troubling thing about what's happening
in Iraq is in my opinion that it has
stoked the resentments among Sunni Arabs
all over the Middle East against the
United States I think at the time of
9/11 we were confronted with a fairly
discrete terrorist organization called
al Qaeda that was headquartered in
Afghanistan and which had some adherents
around the rest of the region I think
that we had the opportunity in 2001 and
2002 to basically dismantle al Qaeda and
that the decision to go into Iraq
so angered and so fueled resentments
among Sunnis all over the Middle East
that we now face a much broader Sunni
insurgency that is more amorphous but in
many ways more dangerous it's no longer
run by Osama bin Laden in the same sense
that al-qaeda was and so you see more
indigenous terrorist cells forming
throughout the Middle East and even in
Europe where there's a large Arab
population which have really only
loosely affiliated loss of Philly ations
with al Qaeda I think that's the big
danger is that Iraq is stoking the the
extremism in the Middle East for the
writers in the classes from conception
to completion how long did it take for
you to finish the book see but oh that's
a good question about a year and a half
we'll go to Pace University next
question Justin Irving go ahead Justin
thanks for joining us today mr. Eisen
I'm gonna take a quick vote from your
afterwards the CIA has suffered so many
spectacular failures and such a rapid
secession that by late 2005 it had lost
its place on standing in Washington do
you see a similar relationship to other
governmental organizations with the lack
of response to an issue that affects
American people like for example FEMA
and Hurricane Katrina and is that
something that you would ever be
interested in writing about in another
book yeah a FEMA is a perfect example of
complete systemic failure by a
government agency that would be a great
book I think some other people are
probably already writing that could
Katrina book Michael Brown is one of
them but no I mean I think that's the
problem I think that the president has
had and I think I really believe that
Katrina had a major effect on his
approval rating in part because it came
on top of Iraq just as Iraq was kind of
deteriorating Katrina happened and so
you had this kind of double whammy
effect and what it showed is it's raised
questions about competence in the
the government will stay with Pace
University I see Callen and Joe and
Clark's hand and Denver will go to you
next I promise but next question from
New York Francis you're up yes some a
certain George Mason University you just
pointed out something that I want to ask
my question I'm with the if if there is
a conclusive connection fine between the
Saudi power elite and al-qaeda how do
you feel the we can pursue that interest
and is there even the possibility of
still pursuing that interest being that
we're so mired hand-in-hand with Saudi
Arabia and the royal family and the
connections to oil and whatnot well
that's that's why nobody wants to get
look into it I mean one of the real
things I it's it's this whole thing I
think of you know ignorant is bliss
sometimes and I think that has affected
the intelligence gathering on Saudi
Arabia that nobody really wants to know
the answer to that question and so that
affects and distorts intelligence
collection if you really wanted to know
what what was the role of the Saudi of I
don't I don't think the Saudi royal
family is involved but if you wanted to
know what the role of the Saudi rich and
powerful people was in the creation and
the sponsorship of al-qaeda you would
have to devote a lot more intelligence
resources than we ever have to
understanding and investigating Saudi
Arabia and we never have done that
Kellen grody in Denver you're next go
ahead please all right thank you um a
lot of times in your book I see like the
idea that the president was not informed
about a lot of things that were going on
or if he was informed about something
that a lot of times like Donald Rumsfeld
will go Ronald he was saying especially
if you look at the example that he
provided of Afghanistan when he ordered
them to or at least said that they
should get rid of all the drug lords and
stuff like that and then Rumsfeld kind
of went around him do you think this is
more indicative of Rumsfeld and Cheney
kind of working on their own agenda
beneath him and trying to kind of under
him or is it more of a result of his
broader policy where he kind of let them
do it they wanted and was sort of felt
like see no evil hear no evil speak no
evil or whatever that's a good question
I tried to sort that out myself I don't
know the really the answer to that as I
said earlier I think that part of it is
just his belief and that his job is to
set these broad vision and then not
really get much into the details and
that Cheney and Rumsfeld have taken
advantage of that I don't know to what
extent he's ever gone back and and tried
to press these people on some of these
things one of the only things people
told me he really felt passionate about
prior to the war was when the Pentagon
made it clear that they wanted to put
Ahmed Chalabi in charge of Iraq to
install basically to install
Chalabi and a group of exiles as the new
government of Iraq the president I was
told repeatedly said no we're not going
to do that we're not going to impose a
government we're gonna have democracy
there and that that was one of the few
times he really went back and you know
put his foot down but there were other
cases on Iraq and Afghanistan where he
didn't and so I've never understood
exactly why that is it's very difficult
for the people but I talked to to
understand it either
we'll stay with Denver Clark you're next
thank you and thanks for being with us
James we appreciate it I my question
first of all I wanted to say I really
enjoyed your book I think there was a
lot of fantastic information provided in
the book um I think one thing one thing
that I feel personally I'm kind of one
of those freaky conspiracy theorists I
think 9/11 could have been prevented
should have been prevented was not
prevented Clark please listen because
let me because you talked about it a
little bit in the book the breakdown of
communication and the George Tennant
taking blame for 9/11 what do you say
the Clark's pointing then we'll come
back to you Clark I promise well I mean
I think there were there were instances
they could have in which they if they
had
did properly they could have possibly
prevented 9/11 I think the most obvious
example is the two hijackers who were in
San Diego who you know were not properly
watch listed by the CIA so there were
cases where they could have they had an
opportunity to take action which and
they didn't go back to your question or
comment Thanks
okay thanks well continuing on with that
point though one one document that is
particularly poignant in my opinion is
what's called the project for the new
American Century which was a I'm sure
you're familiar with that it's a pre
9/11 American policymaking document
which was signed signed by noted
neoconservatives Richard Perle Bill
Kristol among others the document called
for a Pearl Harbor like event that could
provide the context to enter into three
essential missions beginning with a
major presence in the Middle East I'm
just curious
um did you just not want to go there in
the book or I didn't see that I didn't
really see that I've never heard about
that I mean I'm familiar with their
other dock other memos and documents I'm
familiar with particular about a group
led by Doug Feith and Wolfowitz I think
in Pearl where they wrote a memo in the
late in the mid 90s talking about how
getting rid of Saddam housing Saddam
Hussein would be in Israel's national
security interest and that caused a lot
of controversy in Washington when that
resurfaced after I think before or
before after the invasion and so there's
but I don't know about that I've never
heard of that I do think that the the
role of the kind of the neoconservatives
within the Bush administration is still
not well understood and it's something
that I'd I'd like to pursue in the
future Clark I see you shaking your head
did you want to follow up and respond to
James's point I was agreeing I wanted to
thank thank him for you know his honesty
on that issue so I appreciate it that's
all
thanks for the questions let's go to
George Mason next Steve I have a maybe a
series of questions here but they're all
related to what extent that our
intelligence community anticipate the
void that the removal of Saddam Hussein
would create and just how dangerous has
that void become further how can that
void be avoided in the future or is that
now impossible have we unleashed a
movement or momentum that can't be put
back in the bottle well how much time do
you have a good question Steve well if I
knew that if I knew the answer that I'd
be a rich man
I just think Iraq is god I mean it's got
to be the hardest thing right now to
figure out for anybody no matter what
your political views are today to try
and sort out what is going to happen
there I don't think anybody who says
they know what's about to happen there I
think is just blowing smoke I'm gonna
come back to Steve swarm we have some
pictures of President Bush on board the
USS Abraham Lincoln the big banner
behind that said mission accomplished
from a political standpoint a public
relations standpoint how big of a
mistake was that when they write the
history book on this administration well
it's gonna be an iconic moment because
it's like you know it's like declaring
victory if you know when the war is just
starting and there he is
this was just a couple of months after
the war actually begins and more have
died since then of May of 2003 yeah this
was a month after the toppling of Saddam
Hussein and it you know at that point
the administration was thinking about
pulling the troops out and they were
beginning to kind of figure out how to
get out of Iraq a little under with a
little understanding of the insurgency
that was about to start do you want to
respond to the larger point of Steve
Klein's question about the future I just
think that to me
it looks to me like right now it sounds
like a joke but it looks to me like it
would be a mistake for us to get out and
it would be a mistake for us to stay and
so I don't know which way to go I I have
no idea right now
it is a it looks like it's on the verge
of just becoming a total mess who has
the next question from the home of the
Patriots at George Mason Oh John Galt
please
hi earlier you mentioned that the the
current administration is somewhat
reclusive to the public do you think
that due to the dropping ratings that
they will become started to become more
open well I think the president has been
trying a little bit of that lately he's
he's been trying to do a few less
scripted public events than he had been
although it's still kind of like putting
his toe in the water to see how it'll go
I think really it it the public
relations side of it I think they're
beginning to realize now doesn't matter
as long as Iraq continues to go the way
it is Iraq today is like Vietnam for
Bush is like Vietnam was for Johnson in
the sixties everything depends on the
course of the war and what happens in
Iraq if Iraq gets better Bush's approval
will get better if it doesn't then he
and in his approval will stay about the
same I think what do you think if the
president were to read this book would
be the biggest lesson he would take away
from the whole experience yeah well I
would hope that he would see that that
there is a role to be played by you know
what we would call beer what most people
criticized as bureaucrats
I think the flipside of the bureaucracy
is to say that there are experts
professional career experts in the
government who know certain issues what
happened after 9/11 I think between 9/11
and the invasion of Iraq
that 18 month period I think is crucial
in American history today was that the
normal processes for the creation and
the vetting and the deliberation of
foreign policy issues broke down and
that the very scene of a small group of
very senior people were making policies
on the fly without thinking things
through very clearly without consulting
with the experts without kind of vetting
policies throughout the government to
get a clearer understanding of the
consequences of what they were doing and
I think that that you can always
criticize the the bureaucrats and they
deserve a lot of criticism but sometimes
they stop you from doing something that
you shouldn't do and I think that would
might be the lesson you could take Joe
Peller in Denver I haven't forgotten
about you I saw your hand earlier you're
next hi mr. Rosen your chapter about
Saudi Arabia reminds me a lot of the
book blood and oil and how our hands are
based in the back pocket of the Saudi
Arabia's and how we give them billions
of dollars in arms each year but well
your book brought out is the
intelligence side of Saudi Arabia and
how it's like a relationship where we
hold hands with them but yet we don't
talk and we don't really communicate
with each other right I know this was
kind of brought up earlier but I was
wondering if you think I know our
relationship will never be severed with
them mostly because of oil but what are
the necessary steps from the sources
that you've received that would be to
improve our relations with Saudi Arabia
well it's a great question I mean I
think Saudi Arabia is in trouble today
because partly because of the situation
in Iraq which has inflamed the
fundamentalist views in this among the
Sunni community and so I think right now
we're at a difficult point point where
if we push too hard on the Saudis right
now I think the thinking is
you know maybe that whole house of cards
will collapse it's kind of the way we're
now treating Pakistan even though
everyone knows Osama bin Laden is in
Pakistan we don't want to push the
Government of Pakistan too hard to go
find him because we're afraid that that
government might collapse and the
something worse would come up in its
place
I think we're treating Saudi Arabia in
the same way we're afraid to push too
hard because if the royal family falls
and the fundamentalists who are rising
in power there come to power then you
know the oil spigots might get turned
off Steve Kline before we say goodbye to
your group because I know you in class
in a couple of minutes do you have a
final question or comment or one of your
students I think we're fairly satisfied
here and I know there are a lot of
questions in Denver and paste some Steve
so why don't you take those let's go
back to Pace University next question I
found it really disturbing after reading
your book that there were people in the
CIA who knew that some of the
intelligence cited in the run-up to the
war was faulty at best and just seems to
me that there was a real culture of fear
in the CIA and that it got really
politicized and that that was why
sometimes people didn't speak out and
they should have I was wondering if you
thought that was one of the main
problems and if there's anything we
could do to kind of take politics and
some of that bureaucratic nonsense out
of national security decision let me
take what she said culture of fear but
also could you add culture of groupthink
yeah well I think it was both I think
there was a culture of fear within the
CIA because they knew it became very
clear what the Bush administration
wanted what answers they wanted because
they were making public speeches about
the about WMD and about Iraq and so and
you didn't have to you would have to be
blind not to know what the White House
want what answers they wanted that
created a fear I think of people willing
to step forward and say no there is no
WMD it would be like the little boy
saying the emperor has no clothes
and so I think that it was a it would
have taken a major leap of courage act
of courage to actually come out and
raise questions about the intelligence
will stay with New York and Pace
University next question Alesia era I
thank you for being with us I actually
have a quick question do you think that
Rumsfeld and Cheney and even President
Bush had underestimated the power that
Powell was able to obtain because when
you mentioned those names Powell tends
to have more of like a is a positive
aura to him and do you think that his
resignation symbolized something about
the one-sidedness of the current
administration yeah I think what
happened was but by 2004 when he quit he
had basically given up he had been
defeated by Cheney and Rumsfeld and he
knew it and he knew that the war was
going badly and that the president had
really never listened
you know never listened to him and so I
think he kind of realized that it was
time to leave I think he had recognized
that Powell and that Cheney and Rumsfeld
had had the been dominant long before
that you described Colin Powell as a
lion in winter mm-hmm yeah he was a
great man who had the who had enormous
credibility with the American people and
if but but I think he was at the same
time at heart a military man who was
loyal to a fault and he didn't he never
tried to use the political capital that
he had and by never using it inside the
government he lost it
a couple questions in the back in Denver
Doug young did you have a question is
Doug there yeah I did just what we were
talking about sort of George Bush's role
and this whole thing he's come under a
lot of criticism as of late for being
quote out of touch the sources that you
talked to would they describe him that
way and what does that exactly mean I
don't think the people would describe
him as out of touch I think they would
say as I said earlier I think what they
would that
but they don't don't understand is that
when they have a briefing when they and
this Afghan briefing that I described is
a perfect example that he seems to
understand all the issues he seems
animated and interested and ask good
questions but that there doesn't seem to
be a lot of follow-up and that it's in
the follow-up and the implementation
where there is a breakdown and I think a
lot of people have you know never quite
understood why that happens I mean I
think Katrina is a good example of that
where he went to New Orleans promised
billions of dollars of aid and then the
the process broke down after he moved on
to something else I think that's the the
real question is as I said he sets broad
broad vision as a broad vision he sets a
broad agenda he leaves the
implementation to others and I think he
doesn't do enough follow-up an
implementation of his own you okay for a
couple more minutes yeah let's go back
to Denver Amex phone anyone that I've
missed Oh My yes we have lots of
questions okay let's take two we have
time for two okay do you want to cover
Max's question that she emailed us let's
go to the two questions let's take ten
from students her there okay how about
Andrew Hogue who's been waiting and
waiting and waiting
go ahead Andrew thank you and thanks for
joining us again just to step back a
little bit to the CIA prisons started
digress but um it's it seems like
someone mentioned earlier the Geneva
Convention and how we're kind of
stepping around that and and it seems
like any stance on human rights issues
that the United States puts out its kind
of seen as a joke how can we take any of
these seriously if if we have hidden
torture prisons around the world and and
ghost transferring prisoners etc and how
can we take a stance on on third-world
human rights issues when we're
committing them ourselves thanks Andrew
I think that's one of the problems we
now have in our international relations
is that the image of the United States
has been so badly damaged by the Abu
Ghraib scandal and by
related issues that torture and I think
it has hurt our ability to influence
international conventions and on those
kind of issues that the countervailing
thing about that though is that the
United States is a huge superpower and
so we are able to use our info and
economic influence in these
international organizations even when we
are criticized or are having image
problems ourselves it's one of the
things that I think is beginning to make
us look more like an empire around the
world is that you know we are able to
kind of uniquely create our own set of
conditions that we follow in the
interest of time one of the students who
was not able to be here today it was
going to ask you about how you feel
about the debate in this country between
national security and civil liberties
with regard to the NSA well it's it's
one of it's a classic debate in America
that goes back to the founding fathers
and the Constitution that we have a we
always have a debate over how much how
much freedom should we give up in
exchange for a safer or more secure
society and it's a debate that goes back
and forth throughout our history
depending on the circumstances during
Wars we tend to give up more civil
liberties in order to fight a war what I
think was what I've thought about a lot
recently is the fact that now there has
been more time has passed between 9/11
and today than between Pearl Harbor and
the end of World War two and so the
question I ask is at what time do
emergency measures put in place during
wartime become part of the permanent
landscape and the permanent way that we
as a society function and at some point
I think we have to have a debate an open
debate about how long do we put those
kind of measures in place one more
question from Denver and then a final
question from Pace University meg you
select the student in
how about Derek in the middle thank you
I was just wondering if you could expand
a little bit on the end of your book
where you briefly mentioned Porter Goss
and the CIA and I was wondering if you
could maybe characterize some of the
changes at the CIA right now and how his
leadership there has maybe changed its
relationship with other agencies within
the Bush administration and sort of the
direction things are headed thanks Derek
well I think I think the CI today is a
much less powerful organization
politically within the administration
than it was it's been downgraded it you
know John Negroponte a the new Director
of National Intelligence is the guy who
actually does the the briefings for the
President and who is the kind of the
figurehead man in charge of the
intelligence community the CI today is
still trying to sort out what its role
is in this world in which it is no
longer the lead agency on intelligence
and I think that has led to a lot of
people leaving the CIA in the last year
a lot of senior people have quit out of
frustration for me partly because they
don't like goss's management style or
the people around them or the fact that
the agency doesn't seem to have a clear
direction will conclude with one
question from Pace University and Sarah
Leslie has the last question of Isis and
Cheney said that this information eight
of the terrorists now that was published
and he was obviously very mad so have
you experienced any personal backlash
from the publication of this book from
government officials who are angered
that you publish this information or
have you run into any I guess friction
with government officials now that your
name
is on this book yes yeah we've gotten a
lot of hate mail from people who support
the President on this issue and say that
it was we shouldn't have printed it on
the other hand we've gotten a lot of
support from people around the country
who said that it was a public service to
print it I have not been contacted by
anybody in the government about it there
is a leak investigation underway but no
one from the government has contacted me
about that so we have covered a lot in
this last hour and 20 minutes but what
did you take away from all the work that
you put into this book how do you view
this administration and your country
good question I think the thing that
struck me the most was that there were
people a lot of people in the US
intelligence community and elsewhere in
the government who came to believe that
there was they were act secret
activities underway in the US government
that they had not seen in 30 or 40 years
and that there was a radicalization of
national security policy that I felt I
had to write about so I guess that's the
best way to put it
James Rison who writes for the New York
Times and the book that the students in
Denver and George Mason and Pace
University of read on behalf of those
students we want to thank you for
joining us it has been an interesting
hour in 20 minutes we appreciate it
thanks for having me
[Applause]